واضمن ردود الفعل الدوليه على قيود طالبان
دعا وزراء خارجيه دول لمجموعه السابعه
طالبان الى الغاء قرار منع عمل النساء في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه فورا فاصفين في
بيان قرار الحركه بانهور وخطير ويعرض
ملايين الافغان للقطر من جانبها حضرت
وكاله اغاثه كبرى ان مواطنين افغان
سيموتون اذا لم تعود المنظمات للعمل خصوصا
وان افغانستان تواجه واحده من اسوا ازمات
الجوع في التاريخ وفقا المنظمات
من جانبه قال منسقه للامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه في افغانستان انه لجنه الطوارئ
سترسل وفد الرفيعه المستوى من اجل اقناع
طالبا بالتراجع عن قراراتها التي تقييد
حريه المراه في افغانستان
للامم المتحده بزياره الى افغانستان
من اجل العدول عن قرارهم سنحاول ايجاد حل
لهذه المشكله نعتزم ارسال البعثه في
الاسابيع القليله القادمه
الاسلاميه الحسين طاهر ابراهيم
مجمع الفقه الاسلامي الدولي لحشدي موقفه
مشترك من كافه المرجعيات الاسلاميه
والعلماء يدين قرار طالبان لمنع الفتيات
من التعليم وتداعيه
[موسيقى]